experience implementing virtual private  cloud hybrid connectivity and other  network services and establishing  security for the network but i'm looking  for new project opportunities how can i  stand out have you considered google  cloud professional cloud network  engineer certification it's basically a  professional stamp of approval plus  preparing for it will actually solidify  your understanding of implementing and  managing network architectures in cloud  platform sounds like a great  certification to add to my resume any  tips on how to best prepare check out  the exam guide first to learn about all  the domains that are covered in the exam  cool i'll create my study plan based on  that any other resources you would  recommend  there are tons of training resources  from sample questions to hands-on labs  and on-demand courses just check them  out perfect i got this  [Music]